läuferin bevor es losgeht wird natürlich
wieder was verlost die ersten gewinner
vollen ersten verlosungen wurden jetzt
bereits angetönt also check des videos
vielleicht würdet ihr angekündigter
irgendwann ausgesucht heute wird
rausgehauen unter diesem video jetzt ist
ein einsatz marie 3 2 1 1
so zufrieden gehen auch einfach kanal
abonnieren alexy abonnieren und ebenen
kommentar schreiben und ja ich habe
davon noch drei weitere aber die werden
demnächst kommt jetzt viel spaß mit dem
video 3 2 1 hätte das gedacht und
herzlich willkommen zu einem 9 mio also
das war bisher komisch jetzt oder noch
mal herzlich willkommen ich hoffe euch
jetzt gut
heute gibt es ein kleines experiment
oder gut das experiment habe ich schon
vor deutlich länger als einem monat
gestartet aber heute kommt heute das
video dazu es wird wirklich interessant
weil es hätte auch sein können dass es
nicht klappt so wie es mir vorstelle
aber ich war mir schon relativ sicher
das ist auf jeden fall funktionieren
wird ich habe auf meinem youtube kanal
schon zwei videos hochgeladen in denen
ich amazon pakete ausgepackt habe die
ich nie bestellt hatte die wurden damals
alle noch an meine kölner adresse
geliefert und es waren wirklich safe
über 10 und das krasse ist bis vor einem
monat habe ich immer noch pakete dahin
bekommen obwohl meine adresse da gar
nicht also ist mein name ist schon gar
nicht mehr anders single und ein nachbar
hatte dann trotzdem angenommen und mir
nochmal perrot abgeschrieben hey ich
habe wieder pakete von dir bekommen bis
sie abholen und ich wusste hat okay da
ist eh nur schrott drin denen ich nie
bestellt habe als wenn ich jetzt extra
nach köln fahrer und die pakete abholen
dann habe ich gesagt entweder du
schmeißt sie weg oder ich schenk dir und
das verrückte war dann einfach eher so
wie darf ich das jetzt wirklich auf
machen und ich meine ja ich habe das
ähnlich bestellt komplizierte lange
story und er macht das auf und schickt
mir einfach ein foto von so aktiv das
haben wir wirklich ein bisschen
unangenehm von seinem penis ring also da
waren auch noch andere sachen drin aber
halt auf dieser penis ring weil ich habe
auch so sexspielzeuge bekommen die diese
firma hat auch produziert die ganze ware
kommt halt aus china überall steht made
in china darauf die firma sitzt
allerdings in deutschland und verkauft
hier in deutschland über amazon so china
sport und weswegen ich dann jetzt aber
doch noch mal dieses experiment gewagt
habe um der ganzen sache auf den grund
zu gehen viele von euch kann ja sicher
das format real
sind das ist vom swr und die haben auch
so einen typen verfilmt der irgendwie
andauernd amazon pakete bekommen hat
über 100 stück oder so also wirklich
krass viele pakete und er hatte da auch
nur diesen china schrott drin ich
bekomme ständig für den amazon pakete
die ich weder bestellt noch bezahlt hat
und es geht mir mittlerweile tierisch
auf die nerven ich habe auf den ganzen
beitrag auf meinem alex v kanal reagiert
link in der video beschreibung viele
produkte in die leer hatte habe ich auch
bei mir wieder gesehen und in dem video
wurde dann die aussage getroffen ich
muss dafür jetzt ein bisschen weiter
ausholen weil jede person die in gewerbe
hat kann sich bei amazon anmelden und
über amazon verkaufen also theoretisch
jeder von euch auch ich kenne mich da
mittlerweile auch ganz gut aus weil ich
das selber mache so ein bisschen auf
jeden fall wenn du den kunden diesen
prime service bieten möchte ist also
paket wird bestellt und am nächsten tag
ist es da dann musst du deine ganze ware
an diese amazon lagerräume und
lagerhäuser die gibt es ja überall in
deutschland schicken dafür musste
natürlich schon mal eine grundgebühr an
amazon zahlen kommt darauf an wie groß
seine ware ist und wie viel lagerplatz
zu den anspruch nimmst wenn du die ware
allerdings nicht weg christ von da und
die keiner kauft musst du immer mehr
zahlen also ich glaube ich weiß nicht
genau nach im jahr oder so wollen wir
dann halt geld von den und dieser ganz
china schrott der nach deutschland
importiert wird und dann von
irgendwelchen verkäufern hier verkauft
werden möchte den dann aber keiner kauft
der ist günstiger einfach irgendwohin zu
schicken nach deutschland umsonst heißt
das ganze zeug wieder nach china zurück
zu schicken das ist der grundgedanke
dieses beitrags gewesen und da stand
dann das wird willkürlich an
irgendwelche personen in deutschland
rausgeschickt also einfach stumpf
irgendwelche adressen und ich dachte mir
ich glaube das kann ich sein ich muss
auf jeden fall mal experiment wagen und
mein gedankengang war dann ich habe mir
alle produkte oder viele produkte die
ich bekommen habe die ich halt nicht
bestellt hat mir angeschaut geschaut
okay von wo kommt das und das war alles
von der gleichen firma ich weiß nicht ob
ich den namen her einwände oder nicht
keinen plan auf jeden fall eine deutsche
firma die sitzen glaube ich irgendwo in
essen ich glaub ich blende namen nicht
ein weil ich will auch gar nicht dass
ich irgendwie da jetzt mit in verbindung
stehe dass ich das sozusagen aufklärung
oder so ich weiß ja nicht ob das in
irgendeiner form schaden es sei denn sie
schicken mir ist jeden tag zehn pakete
weil da habe ich auch keinen bock drauf
aber ich habe mir diese adresse
rausgesucht und hat mit guckt okay du
hast in letzter zeit oft bei amazon
bestellt das war diese zeit wo ich
andauernd so amazon unboxing es gemacht
habe und habe dann zwei produkte
gefunden die ich wirklich von dieser
firma über amazon bestellt habe eins
darf
man war ein handtuch ja das war ich kann
es euch ja wenn das war einfach dieses
stumpfe handtuch und meine überlegung
ist dann gewesen ich war bei denen
anscheinend gelistet mit der adresse ich
hab bei den bestell und dann gehen halt
einfach diese ganzen sachen die die
nicht verkauften auch an kunden von
denen raus die irgendwann mal bei dem
gestellt haben dann habe ich gedacht
okay passt auch du bestellst es einfach
noch mal dann habe ich eines dieser
beiden produkte noch mal hierhin
bestellt das ist habe ich schon vorab
safe vor zwei monaten gemacht habt euch
gleich mal zeigen aber ist eigentlich
auch unwichtig und dann dachte ich mir
ich bin jetzt wieder mit dieser adresse
weil ich bin ja umgezogen hier wieder
bei denen gelistet wartest du einfach
mal vielleicht kommt ja wieder was so
weil ich dachte mir ist immer cool für
videos so was halt auszupacken und ja
dann habe ich gewartet und gewartet und
gewartet und nach ungefähr einem monat
am ein kleines paket an mit irgendwas
drin was ich nicht bestellt haben sollte
ich glaube das erste paket ist weil ich
hatte die letzten wochen nichts mehr zu
bestellen ich kann das mal kurz holen so
da bin ich wieder moment ein relativ
kleines paket auch nur aber wenn man das
ausmacht kommt direkt schon wieder hier
wie ich es erwartet habe ganz fett made
in china ja okay also das ist schon
wieder anderen dingen und das ganze
natürlich von dem lieferanten bei dem
ich auch vorher dieses handtuch bestellt
habe also das ist auch wieder von dieser
firma aus essen und dann kamen wieder
eine lange zeit nichts und jetzt kam
gestern ein neues paket was sich mieter
nicht bestellt habe und dann habe ich
mir gedacht jetzt kannst du endlich mal
das video dazu machen und das ist der
beweis dafür wie deshalb funktioniert
das heißt wenn ihr aus versehen irgendwo
bestellt bei so einem typen der viel
china schrott verkauft in riesigen
mengen dann kann es passieren dass ihre
ware kriegt die wir jetzt aber trotzdem
noch mal eben auspacken ja also das ist
ganz klar ich bin mal gespannt was jetzt
wieder dabei ist kommt man mit wir gehen
mal rüber ins büro okay da bin ich
wieder beschaffen einfach mal mit diesem
paket das es wie gesagt schon vor
ungefähr einem monat angekommen und
gestern ist dann dieses paket angekommen
ich habe allerdings hier auch schon
reingeguckt weil ich noch ziemlich viel
aktuell auch gerade wegen weihnachten
wir aber zum gestellt habe und die hätte
auch was anderes drin sein können aber
das was da drin ist habe ich definitiv
nicht bestellt das habe ich euch ja
gerade schon gezeigt made in china steht
drauf ich bin gespannt
es wird wahrscheinlich wieder
irgendeinen booms sein aber vielleicht
ist es ja auch mal was brauchbares
circle model s ko das liegt schon wieder
aus
verdächtiges spielzeug aber schauen wir
mal den rasierer also sogar sonja also
die marke kenne ich nicht stärker also
damit kann ich wenigstens mal was
anfangen falls wer möchte nicht komplett
webbasiert im gesicht und einen schwanz
gut aus
[Applaus]
also ich habe irgendwie ein bisschen ans
ja ich habe jetzt auch nicht so denn bat
deswegen kann man hier wahrscheinlich
keine ja ich glaube der funktioniert den
muss ich auf jeden fall mal ein bisschen
genauer testen das ist halt also das ist
einfach nur so eine art von produkt du
kannst über sämtliche webseiten diese
chinesischen hersteller kontaktieren und
die dann von denen dein produkt bauen
lassen selbst mit verpackung und so also
ich denke mal das ist halt einfach ein
rasierer und der markt ist sehr was weiß
ich genau das gleiche produkt gibt
wahrscheinlich auch noch von 100 anderen
marken aber so läuft das dann halt dann
kommen die nach deutschland und werden
verkauft ich bin euch auch jemand den
preis sein beteuerte ist aber damit kann
ich auf jeden fall schon mal was alleine
hier haben wir jetzt drinnen dachte
scheiße ohren reiniger ihr klima
nein hier haben wir sogar hier steht
sogar drauf made in germany
ich kann das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen warmes wasser in einer
schüssel vorbereiten wasser mit ohren
spritze aufsaugen führen sie die ohren
dusche behutsam circa ein bis zwei bier
ohne witz das ist mache ich mich damit
war damit soll man seine ohren sauber
machen das ist halt wieder so ein
absoluter schrott und hier haben wir
noch ein auch ein portemonnaie herren
ledergeldbörse aus echtem leder
querformat die vier mal die diese ganzen
chinesischen produkte nach deutschland
importiert die schreiben dann manchmal
machen wir noch diese codes traub und da
steht dann auch der deutsche name drauf
weil bei jedem produkt was man über
amazon verkauft braucht man halt sondern
das sind sicher sind wenn ihr bock habt
erzähle ich mal mehr zu diesem ganzen
thema dann lasst einfach meinen daumen
nach oben da also was ich alles so da
mache auf amazon herren ledergeldbörse
mit rechtschreibfehler allerdings aber
dass wir dann halt einfach von dem
chinesischen hersteller noch
draufgepackt deswegen halt dann diese
deutsche bezeichnung darauf hier haben
wir dieses produkt ist außer thema kurz
war
dieses produkt ist aus hochwertigem
leder gefertigt ich muss sagen mein
portemonnaie ist schon ein bisschen in
die jahre kommen damit kann ich auch was
anfangen wir haben tatsächlich jetzt
zwei sachen die gar nicht mal so
schlecht sind aber das war's dann leider
auch schon ich werde auf jeden fall
weiter berichten ob jetzt noch mehr
kommen wird ich gehe stark davon aus
dass hier einiges eintreffen wird und
ich habe halt nur ein bisschen angst
davor dass sich dann darauf sitzen
bleiben und andere und pakete kriege
weil du kannst keine hilfe von amazon
erwarten ich habe mit denen schon
telefoniert die meinten die helfen mir
und kleinen fall aus ab nie mehr was
gehört die haben da
keinen einfluss drauf was diese ganzen
lieferanten da weg schicken das ist
können die halt alles nicht
kontrollieren und ich kann das auch
verstehen dass wir sehr gern nach oben
da und ich würde euch trotzdem nicht
empfehlen euch jetzt auch diese produkte
zu bestellen und dann warten ob ihr
darauf was umsonst kriegt weil es kann
wirklich gefährlich werden und auch
nervig werden gerade wenn er noch zu
hause bei ihren eltern wohnt das dann
plötzlich eure eltern immer pakete
annehmen müssen uns weiter lasst es
besser wirklich auch an die jüngeren
geht jetzt nicht zu ihren eltern und
sagt mama alex hat das bestellt ich will
das jetzt auch dann kriegen wir ganz
viel schrott umsonst das wird einfach
nur nervig und aufwändig seien deswegen
lass die finger davon gut gemeinter rat
und ich kann auch nicht garantieren das
ist in jedem fall natürlich funktioniert
ich bestelle wirklich sehr sehr viel
über amazon ich bin da bestimmt ein sehr
guter kunde kann auch sein dass es da
nur an die besten kunden rausgeschickt
ich weiß es nicht ein paar das war es
danke fürs zuschauen nimmt unbedingt am
adventskalender gewinnspiel teil
einige wurden angezündet wie gesagt und
ja weiter geht's wir sehen uns
übermorgen wieder gibt's neues video out
rein
ich habe zehn ipads bestellt die werden
auch weiter verkaufen es jetzt weiß ich
freue mich